do you think that you are capable of
changing people's minds about the roles
that you're set to play so you don't
have to play either the friend or the
love interest but you want to buy
something more serious yeah yeah I do
think I can do that and I hope I can i
get the chance to that sometime but yes
i do believe that i am more than the
best friend or the love interest but i'm
surprised by the number of breakdowns
that I see is like I'll see these
breakdowns and they're like it's an
entirely white cast is like not a single
person of color oh and I'm like how the
hell is that a reflection of real life
you drive around Los Angeles and you
just look at the people or New York or
any major city you know minorities the
african-american in probably 10 to 12
the fifteen percent of population
Hispanics are probably thirty or forty
percent well how do you do a movie
that's set in modern times and Los
Angeles and don't have a single person
of color in it and it just you know it
just amazes me like I couldn't do a
movie with an all-black cast because it
wouldn't be reflective of reality you
know so you know sometimes frustrating
button the number of roles that just
aren't available and then the ones that
are there's still the stereo is still a
stereotype that's there and you know
hopefully one day that will change I
feel like the struggle is not
necessarily in the casting room now I
feel like the struggle is now with
encouraging writers to write those
interesting roles because now in the
casting room people are more aware and
mindful and so if there is
discrimination or stereotypes or even
racism it's a little bit more tactful
you know they're not as blatant about it
they're not going to say oh will you do
martial arts even if they might be
thinking about it they won't say it
because you know it's a little more of a
political conversation now so people are
more mindful but I don't think that it
means that the paradigm isn't there or
that order that the the thinking where
the logic isn't there because
you know sort of old habits an old
behavior so I think that you still see a
residual effect of it they're physically
my type limits me because people look at
me and they see I'm really skinny so i
will get cast as gay characters or just
like really like the comic relief type
characters in like plays but my voice
and you know Glenn's me to do things
like Titus Andronicus and or aaron and
titus andronicus by William Shakespeare
I can do the tragedy of Coriolanus by
William Shakespeare I have a really like
strong speaking voice for the for that
language so it really just depends like
I like to go to auditions and really
like wow people like to say like oh I
wasn't expecting this kind of people to
do that they were talking among
themselves and that's the first
impression that I that I got where they
looked at eight one another and they
said well what do you think he makes a
good show low or he makes a good you
know gangster and that was it I mean
they were there wasn't any more no girls
you know those were pretty much it for
me I have mixed feelings about it you
know once again it's a blessing just to
be casting anything so I still try to
say optimistic about what I'm being
casted for even if it's something that I
am you know starts to be overwhelmed
with like I'm says I'm gonna educated
man you know I know you know exterior
can come office you know that's typical
you know social stereotype but once
again I have so much to offer so with
that being said I would like to do that
with my characters and you know and get
to play other rows and you know
experience other roles and other
characters that I know that are out
there versus spins still you know
confined to that one how your black guy
so you're the bad guy you're a black guy
hey you're the drug dealer you know it
sounds like I said it does become
discouraging but once again it's just a
blessing to be able to get to act period
I'm not a drug dealer or bad guy so I'm
acting so once again I do take it as a
person and just look at it optimistic in
the beginning it was fun but then I got
kind of more frustrating big
I wanted to to show what I got and what
I can do and what I can act and because
there's a lot of typecasting of the
feeling and in this industry it was
really or it is really hard for me to
actually you know get dramatic will
roles a god for them or do you know to
to be the protagonist and whatever
they're looking for because they don't
see me as one and they won't cast me as
one I have the feeling because I've
never gone out for the big major roles
in you know web series of movies or
whatever why can't just black women be
normal people and I feel like the media
of the entertainment industry impacts
how people look at other cultures primex
I know this is deteriorating from what
you said but an example was I was
hanging out some of my friends from
Japan they just started interacting with
black people me and my golfer where the
first black girls I've ever hung out
with and they've kept asking I was like
do you guys talk like this why don't you
guys say that and I'm like wow and
that's what they see in movies because
black girls are like this and in music
videos black girls are shaking their
asses but you had me my girl and my
girlfriend over proper and we spoke very
we speak very good English that they
were so shocked you know so that's what
that's the way media portrays black
women
and it brings the money right so some
people you just you have to go for the
money because I mean you have to survive
all right growing up in the projects you
see another sense of the world and you
want to bring that out and that's why
you know ever since I was a kid I've
always wanted to be an actor to show
people that and at first I was very
reluctant I was like you know what this
is not we're not just your gangsters or
your mobsters your drug cartels or your
janitors were you know we're businessmen
we're lawyers were you know you know
working father in the fields you know
etc and i think i did at the service to
myself and to the public by really
really not not taking on those roles and
so now you know in hindsight now I'm
embrace it wholeheartedly I do embrace
it with the passion to to show those you
know much emotional intangible elements
that you know the the audience wouldn't
wouldn't know they they exist so now I
actually tackled those projects on
purpose I have several Mexican American
actor friends or some of them are Latin
American you know South American or
whatever and they get really frustrated
because they have to go in there and
play the gangbanger and and they get
frustrated and for me you know we live
in LA and so the Hispanic population is
really really big here its prominent and
a lot of the writers in LA are very
aware of that culture they're aware of
sort of the fact that a lot of people
here in LA speak Spanish and you almost
have to you and so a lot of that filters
into the material that we we do here in
LA and so for me I say to him well at
least you're getting jobs man you know
and I know a lot of my friends who are
middle eastern you know I mean like
years ago you know after nine eleven you
know when we're dealing with Homeland
Security you know that became such a big
big prominent sort of piece of the
conversation
and I had friends who were Middle
Eastern and they were suddenly were
working you know because that became you
know a centerpiece for the country in
terms of how shows that we see and so
you know it was really interesting you
know so one side you're like ah but is
that is like hey man you're working but
I do think that i think in Hollywood I
whether you're white or or or you know
minority I think there's truth to what
you said which is that they have to know
what type you are before you can start
stretching yourself
you